there's a woman who had an Iowa town hall
confronted a Anti Obamacare Republican Senator
Chuck Grassley over the weekend.
And the video of the confrontation has gone
viral and I'm gonna play it for you in a moment,
but to set it up, one of the saddest things
about conservative, strict father morality
in the United States is the complete and total
lack of empathy that pervades right wing elected
officials who sort of subscribe to that, um,
political philosophy or ideology.
And there are all these stories we've heard
over the years of a homophobic, anti gay republican
who learned their child's gay and suddenly
they have a change of heart.
There are no longer as anti gay, there are
no longer as opposed to gay adoption or gay
marriage or whatever.
And I've explained before, okay, it's good
that these right wing homophobes suddenly
saw LGBT rights differently once it affected
them personally and they came over to the
right position.
But why does it need to affect them personally
before they can actually empathize with other
people who are in a particular situation every
single time that a conservative homophobe
sees the light on gay rights?
Okay, it's good, but can't we as the thinking
species, as Homo Sapiens, can't, we use abstract
thinking to imagine what it would be like
to have a gay or lesbian child and see that
the law is stacked against them and see that
there is discrimination implicit in our society
even if we don't actually have a gay child.
And we've seen similar confrontations happen
to what I'm about to show you along Harold
healthcare lines, before we're a sick person
will confront a lawmaker who wants to pass
a law that will lead to tons of people losing
their healthcare and some portion of those
people losing their lives.
In Iowa over the weekend.
It was Robin stone.
Robin stone has a preexisting condition.
She confronted Chuck Grassley about how what
he wants to do with healthcare, what he's
voted to do multiple times with the affordable
care act act puts her life at risk and it
escalated very quickly and I understand why
Robin's stone got mad in this video.
Grassley played this game where he pretends
that the threat to the affordable care act
is that it might be declared unconstitutional,
but Robin's stone reminds him.
Well, aside from the constitutionality, you
voted to repeal Obamacare multiple times and
he gets all blubber mouth and tries to make
excuses and then he actually, if you're watching,
you'll see him lean over and start to berate
this woman as if she's the stupid one, even
though it's his position and his party's position.
That is unconscionable.
Here, take a look at the video
people who are on our parents because the
courts made there.
I'm not, I don't think.
Yes.
First of all, it's not going to get repealed.
I want you to answer me personally as a person
whose life depends on insurance.
I would be dead in six days or less without
the affordable care act.
Yes.
There's no question about the affordable care
act and so on.
The land and the sacrum may reveal, but congress,
you think it's going to be revealed the last
time we voted for Mccain voted the other way
and there's no chance to reveal it and decided
simply pass it in the sentence.
So what are you worried about?
Chuck Grassley is calming her down by saying,
don't worry, you'll get treatment for your
preexisting condition and you'll get your
medications because we have Obamacare.
And she's saying, that's what I'm confronting
you about.
You want to get rid of Obamacare.
That's exactly why I'm here asking you this
question.
And he insists.
Well, Obamacare is the law.
What are you so worried about?
She's worried about you chuck, because you
and your cronies have voted to get rid of
it multiple times in the house.
It was what?
60 votes in the Senate?
Many votes.
She says seven.
I don't know the exact number.
And meanwhile, and this is, I mean, let this
sink in for a moment.
The sickness of this, her taxes pay for Chuck
Grassley's health insurance, right?
If Chuck Grassley had an ounce of moral rectitude
in his body, you would say, you know what,
Robyn, I empathize with you.
That sounds really stressful.
I can't even imagine dealing with your illness
while also being worried about losing your
care.
I don't you to lose your care.
Here's why I think you will be better off
with an alternative to Obamacare.
Like I disagree with that assertion unless
you're saying single payer of some kind, but
at least then we can have the real debate,
which is, which system works best?
Does Chuck Grassley actually have a viable
alternative to Obamacare that's not Grassley's,
uh, an actual situation?
He doesn't actually have a good alternative
to Obamacare, but at least it'd be an honest
debate.
Instead, he's playing these games.
Well, listen, we have the affordable care
act and I don't think it's going to be found
unconstitutional, so don't worry about it.
Which excuses him from having to actively
throw the, uh, affordable care act in the
trash, or at least tried to every time the
Senate takes a vote on it.
Truly a disgusting human being, Chuck Grassley,
who should be voted out immediately and congratulations
to Robin stone because in those situations,
um, it can be very easy.
You know, you think of your question and you
go in and you're ready and then all of a sudden
it's the middle of the town hall and you get
a chance to ask it.
And she, you know, she, like many others do
a good job of getting the question out, but
then they immediately get sort of hypnotized
by the way that senators and many lawmakers
are able to sort of defuse or distract or
misdirect with talking points.
Like, I don't think you have to worry.
It's not going to be found unconstitutional.
She didn't take her eye off the ball, which
is forget about what the Supreme Court decides
if ever it does.
Uh, about the constitutionality.
You actively voted multiple times to remove
this from part of our healthcare infrastructure,
which would potentially kill me.
And she did a really great job of not sort
of losing the thread there.
Grassley's gotta be voted out.
They've all got to be voted out.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show
on Instagram at David Pakman show and while
he was there, follow me at David Dot patch
quick break back after this